one of the the things you want to see is
for the EU to designate the Iranian
National Guard as a terrorist group they
are really
regards is not just a threat for
Iranians
I'm being very clear of course my people
are getting killed women are being shot
in their faces
many women lost their eyes many men
young men being blinded
by revolutionary guards
in 2019 the Iranian regime shut down the
internet and killed um 1500 people only
in three days this is the Revolutionary
guards
only in three days
and what happened
the whole world didn't do anything
revolutionary guards still are not being
designated as a terrorist organization
that's why they you know have no reason
to stop killing people inside Iran but
the Revolutionary regards
is the one sending drones to Putin to
kill innocent ukrainians so you see
for us Iranians it's clear that the
Revolutionary guards is a terrorist
organization but I don't get it how come
that the West isolate Putin
but when it comes to Harmony who is
helping Putin to kill innocent
ukrainians then they hesitated to put
revolutionary guards in the terrorist
list I don't really get that the
Revolutionary guards is a threat to
people in Iraq in Syria in Yemen is a
threat for the whole region so that's
why I asked um President Biden for a
meeting in person to ask him actually to
take the lead because United the state
of America
put the Revolutionary guards in the
terrorist list and they have the power
they can actually uh
convince their own allies the EU to do
the same again as as just about any
American would share the fact that they
targeted you and American on American
soil uh is
just shocking and Beyond the panel and
it shows that there really is no limit
to what the Iranian government will
consider uh to suppress and oppress its
own people it was not even just me the
Iranian regime targeted the former
officials here
uh Mike Pompeo Brian hook uh Rudy
Giuliani I think and many other Iranian
dissidents and it's not only here in
America right now that I'm talking to
you the UK citizen U.S citizen the
Swedish citizen German citizen French
citizen they're all are in Iranian
prison and they're being used like
bargaining chip that's terrible so
imagine a day imagine a day that all the
leaders of democratic countries get
United in Australian regime instead of
just saying that okay let's negotiate no
the assemble public understand only one
language language of pressure put
pressure on them downgrade your
diplomatic relation and ask the Iranian
regime to release all the political
prisoners all the innocent prisoners
that that's how it works not just saying
that okay you know we are all for human
rights in America we are all for
equality in Europe we are for democracy
but you are not as
United as dictators Putin and Harmony
madora China everywhere dictators are
more united than Democratic countries
that's not acceptable we have to be
United against autocracy and dictators
yeah you made this case at the world
economic Forum very recently uh and and
how was that experience in Davos oh my
God
I had a hard time actually to get clear
answer from the chancellor of Germany
because I actually asked him clear
question that why why don't you put the
Revolutionary guards in the terrorist
list
isn't that the terrorist organization
killing people German citizens are being
now integrated by this regime didn't get
a clear response because it was like you
know we're working with our allies
friend French government
um yeah we condemn that we sanction but
this is not going to work look even
um people inside Iran they say that
we're ready to die but we're not going
to give up
even even teenagers writing on their
social media saying that this might be
our last day oh terrible yeah because
look they want to have normal life
one of the woman you know what she she
said to me she sent a video of herself
walking unveiled and she said that my
mom is scared that I'm gonna be another
massage and I told my mom that mom
you're worried that I'm gonna get killed
like my saw I'm already a dead person
when I don't have freedom when I don't
have freedom to choose what I want to
wear when I don't have freedom to dance
when I don't have freedom to sing when I
don't have freedom to go to Stadium I'm
a dead person
this is the true face of the Islamic
Republican revolutionary guards so in
World economic from I I gave them a
pretty good picture of what's going on
in Iran but sometimes
I don't know money
I don't know what like
business what stopped the leaders of G7
to get United and do their duty to
support democracy to protect democracy
on one level I'm glad that you were
there to make the case uh I've never
been to Davos and people sometimes ask
me like hey uh what's it like and I was
like I don't know I've never been so on
one hand I was I was glad they invited
you uh on the other hand you know it
doesn't seem like they got the message
though hopefully I hope they're gonna
get it but look
the government took everything away from
us Iranians but not hope
I've been shouting for years and years
that
we have to get United but I see a change
of
um like
I see that the the leaders of the
democratic countries finally they're
changing their tone but we need we need
more concrete actions yes I'm hopeful
that finally uh they're hearing us
[Music]
foreign